now that zack snyder's justice league
has finally been released
fans will be clamoring for more from the
dc extended universe but what should you
actually expect to see in the future
these are the hottest upcoming movies in
the dc eu
mere days before the release of wonder
woman 1984 in december 2020
warner brothers announced that a third
movie in the blockbuster franchise was
officially in development
patty jenkins director and co-writer of
the first two films
will also return to finish out the
trilogy of hugely popular
entries in the dc eu just now plot
details are pretty scarce
although jenkins has implied to den of
geek that cheetah the secondary villain
of wonder woman 1984 could return
that movie ends with barbara still alive
but not fully in her cheetah element
anymore
jenkins explained i have my reasons for
making it ambiguous
but the truth is there may or may not be
more to come even more vague than the
plot of the next wonder woman film is
its release date
indeed the movie probably won't make its
way to theaters for quite some time
while warner brothers fast-tracked
production on wonder woman 3
the previous two movies put gal gadot
and jenkins in such high demand that
they're going to be very busy for the
next few years
for one the two are collaborating on a
cleopatra movie while jenkins herself is
said to direct the 2023 star wars
spin-off rogue squadron
wonder woman's backstory is steeped in
legend leaning heavily on the world of
greek myth
most notably the lasso wielding hero is
really named diana
and she is the daughter of hippolyta the
queen of the amazons an all-female
warrior race who live in a utopian
society
on the island of themyscira in the dc eu
so far
fans have been given just a few
tantalizing glimpses into
the lives and culture of the amazons but
according to patty jenkins
a movie about wonder woman's people will
eventually come to theatres
and it'll be vitally important to the
franchise too she told total film
there's an
arc that they have in mind for the first
movie and then the second movie and then
the amazon movie
and then the third movie she and former
dc entertainment president
jeff johns even knocked out a story for
the amazon's movie
and quickly sold the idea to movie
studio brass
jenkins also added that although she
probably won't be in the director's
chair for this one
she'll certainly be on board as producer
in 2019
warner brothers released aquaman an
origin story underwater adventure
featuring the half human half man from
atlantis who has dominion over the sea
in february 2019 shortly after aquaman
crossed the 1 billion
mark at the worldwide box office warner
brothers officially scheduled aquaman 2
for a december 16
2022 release aquaman co-writer david
leslie johnson mcgoldrick will pen the
second movie script as a solo gig while
the original movie's director james 1
will return to helm the sequel the main
cast will all be back too
including amber heard as mira patrick
wilson as orm
and of course jason momoa as arthur
curry himself
the 2019 superhero comedy shazam may be
the tonal opposite of justice league
but the films do exist in the same
universe henry cavill was even supposed
to cameo in shazam at one point which is
also loaded with references to other
justice league heroes shazam tells a
story of teenage foster kid billy batson
who was given the power to turn into an
adult superhero simply by calling out
hey just him
oh hey there son oh hey there other sun
that i also have that's related to that
sun i just passed in the hallway
despite its differences from the rest of
the dc eu
and not having quite the same name
recognition as the other movies shazam
was a hit
earning 365 million dollars at the box
office
and that can mean only one thing a
sequel was inevitable
two weeks after the release of shazam
the rap reported that the original
film's director david f sandberg had
been hired to helm another installment
then at the 2020 dc fandom members of
the production announced the film
subtitle
fury of the gods although they didn't
reveal much else a previously announced
release date of april 1
2022 was pushed to november 4th 2022.
due to coronavirus related production
and theatrical lockdowns
and was later moved again to june 2nd
2023
just as batman has the joker and
superman has lex luthor shazam has black
adam
it's super powered morally ambiguous and
nion unstoppable arch nemesis black adam
is also something of an ancient
anti-hero and playing kim will be one of
the most bankable stars in hollywood
dwayne the rock johnson neither warner
brothers nor dc have let out many
details about the plot
although the cast list includes such
notable actors playing gold comics
favorites like noah centeno as atom
smasher
aldis hodge as hawkman and quintessa
swindell as cyclone
all of you around the world right now
watching i can promise you this i give
you my word
that we are gonna go beyond your wildest
expectations filming on black adam was
set to begin in the summer of 2020
with a release date of december 22nd
2021
but both were delayed due to coronavirus
concerns now
principal photography is set to begin in
april 2021
meaning the film won't be ready until
2022 at the earliest
the arrowverse has had its own flash
show since 2014
starring grant augustine as a super
speedster barry allen
now though warner brothers are set to
bring another flash project into play
a feature film following the dceu
version of the character ezra miller
will once again take up the role of
barry allen in the flash
scheduled for a theatrical release on
november 4th 2022
the film is said to be an adaptation of
the 2011 flash comic flashpoint
in which the flash travels to the past
to stop the killing of his mother and
wreaks havoc on time as a result
most notably these timeline shenanigans
have set the stage for the return of
both michael keaton as the 1989 batman
and ben affleck as a dceu's own caped
crusader
in february 2021 deadline reported that
the young and the restless star sasha
kaye had also joined the cast of the
flash as a significant character
superman's cousin cara zoro but could
the flash be setting up a solo supergirl
movie for kaye
only time will tell in one of the more
memorable scenes in aquaman
some monstrous undersea creatures
attacked the titular superhero
and his fellow atlantean mirror these
mysterious deep sea dwelling monsters
are the trench
one of the tribes of atlantis a few
months after aquaman's release
it was announced at the opening of an
aquaman attraction at warner brothers
studio tour hollywood that a movie about
these trench-dwelling
characters was in the works producer
peter safran told the hollywood reporter
we always even from the early concept
art days loved the idea of a trench
movie
we just knew that we had something very
special there and we knew what that
movie should be
safran also noted that aquaman and mira
will definitely not be characters in the
horror-oriented movie
which will be set after the events of
the first aquaman
and will ideally hit theaters before
aquaman 2.
centering on criminals that had at some
point terrorized the dc universe
suicide squad was a darkly comic
offshoot from the world of the justice
league
written and directed by david air
critics hated the 2016 bad guy
extravaganza but it also won an oscar
made over 746 million dollars at the box
office
and led to two semi-sequels birds of
prey and the forthcoming the suicide
squad
a slightly different named film written
and directed by guardians of the galaxy
mastermind james gunn
will once again find a motley crew of
wicked male contents together to save
the day
and in this case destroy a latin
american nazi era prison
according to producer peter safran the
cast of the suicide squad will include
returning characters like margot robbies
harley quinn
joel kinnaman's rick flack andrei
courtney's captain boomerang
idris elba and john cena also join up as
bloodsport and peacemaker respectively a
sequel is scheduled for an august 6
2021 release check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you